hey big guy Suns getting real low lord
of thunder god of thunder hatch
I have never met this man in my life
he's my brother
adopted Loki's beyond reason but he is
about God and he's my brother
he killed 80 people in two days he's
adopted hey everybody
Suns getting real low hopefully you've
had a chance to see Thor Ragnarok this
is gonna be my Easter Egg video so just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
it yet but there's a lot of infinity war
stuff coming up so be sure you subscribe
to get everything and they'll be
giveaway stuff at the end of the video
too but sort of that funny Hulk line
from Avengers age of Ultron where Black
Widow tries to calm him down
some of the music hues there were a lot
of auditory Easter eggs like things that
they lifted from previous Avengers films
that they turned into jokes there were
stories that they told like when Thor
would tell funny stories about stuff
that Loki would do to him to trick him
that was pulled right out of the comics
so there were a lot of practical Easter
eggs there were a lot of prop Easter
eggs which is like beta ray bill on the
side of the trash planet so this isn't
necessarily in order of appearance but
I'll start with the beta ray bill one so
obviously on stack R which is a big
reference for the Planet Hulk storyline
pretty much that whole part of the movie
is taken from Planet Hulk with a lot of
Jack Kirby mixed in along with Flash
Gordon so the deal with beta ray bill
Kevin Feige explained that they actually
had a version of him in the film the
character was actually in the film at a
certain point but it was such a small
amount of him that they felt like people
would complain just as much as they're
complaining now because he's not in the
film so standard operating procedure for
them is that if they can't do like a
really awesome version of it then
they'll just save it for a future movie
so that does mean that they will do beta
ray bill eventually they just didn't say
which film he'll appear in probably one
of the space-based films but the other
person here with the two faces is by
beast that's a Hulk villain you also
probably recognize Ares God of War and I
know there's a lot of confusion because
he's also a DC character but technically
you can't copy rag characters that are
taken from other people's mythologies so
there's a version of Ares that existed
somewhere in the Marvel Universe now
because he's on the side of the trash
palace and there's one in the DC
Universe too but the whole idea with the
Fei
is on the palace is is that they are the
former winners of the contest of
Champions so like Hulk is the current
winner in the contest of Champions is
actually an Easter Egg for the mobile
free to play a game that Marvel has like
you can actually play a video game
called the contest of Champions but we
meet Valkyrie she's called scrapper 1:42
that's a reference to the Incredible
Hulk number 142 which featured an
appearance of one of the versions of
Valkyrie
so obviously Tessa Thompson doesn't look
like Brunhilde Valkyrie from the comics
but in the flashback scene where you
learn why it was she abandoned Asgard
she gets saved from Helles attack by a
blonde Valkyrie who eats her sword that
blonde Valkyrie is the Brunhilde
Valkyrie it obviously you know hella
from the comics is the goddess of death
she's the daughter of a Loki from a
previous iteration of Ragnarok so
Ragnarok is a regular recurring thing in
the Thor comics the most recent time
Thor allowed it to destroy Asgard and
thereby ending the cycle of Ragnarok so
inserter has that big funny speech about
the prophecy about how he's destined to
destroy Asgard and Thor's like yeah yeah
yeah get to the point what's going on
here he allows it to happen in the movie
so that implies that they're never going
to have another version of Ragnarok
again in there moving Asgard to
somewhere in Norway that place where
Odin died and said you know what this
would actually be a really good place
for Asgard and when he says Asgard isn't
a place it's a people what are you the
god of hammers and helps store sort of
find the inner force within himself
that's the movies version of the Thor
force so the mechanics of how his powers
work in the comics are a little bit
different so the whole idea in the movie
is is that he never needed the hammer it
was only there to help focus his
lightning power so he is a legit god of
the Marvel Cinematic Universe in the
comics the hammer itself is sort of like
the sentient cosmic storm that's trapped
within the hammer so the hammer itself
is alive and it decides who's worthy
enough to wield it so there actually is
something inside the hammer in the
comics but the Thor force in the comics
is really just what the odinforce is
called when Thor absorbs Odin's power
when he eventually died
so the movies explained that Thor is
actually more powerful than Odin but
that's one of the changes from the
comics when Thor makes the joke to
Surtur didn't my father kill you or
something that's actually a reference to
the original creation of the odinforce
so in the comics what happened is his
Odin had two brothers the three of them
went to defeat Serdar but Sir Dirk illed
Odin's brothers Odin absorbed their life
force and that became the odinforce that
empowered him but in the movie they're
just explaining that he always had it
and he draws his power from Asgard but
like they say in the movie the longer
hellah is on Asgard the more powerful
she gets it's the same thing for Thor
the closer to Asgard he is the more
powerful he is the fact that they
destroy it at the end of the movie
doesn't mean that Thor loses his powers
guardians of the galaxy to style so
Peter quill is the son of one of the
elders of the universe the source that
he draws his power from is ego himself
so once ego dies the plant is destroyed
Peter loses his immortality in that like
extra god power that he possesses so
I'll probably need to do a separate
video about this about how powerful Thor
is but Asgard is a people it's not a
place so as long as Asgard like the
people exist Thor will still have his
power his extra power the deal with the
AI if you're not a big comic book reader
is is that in future timelines you see
old versions of Thor he pretty much
looks exactly like Odin with one eye so
that was just sort of him taking the
mantle like oh okay
now you look like Onan and you also are
a functional version of him because
you're king of Asgard
but that whole funny prophecy about
Ragnarok that server keeps reciting is
from the Walt Simonson comics the Serdar
saga where he literally lights his sword
and the eternal flame and uses it to
destroy a scart or try to destroy Asgard
but the whole thing is is it up until
the most recent version of Ragnarok in
the comics Thor Odin has allies were
always able to stave it off in defeat
Surtur speaking of which the army of the
undead Odin's vault hella uses the
eternal flame to resurrect the undead
Asgardian soldiers that have been
entombed beneath Odin's vault that just
them doing the version of hell as power
from the comics she controls a portion
of Asgardian Souls so she can raise an
army of the dead hella says want to see
what real power looks like that's Loki's
line from The Avengers movie - which
Nick Fury says let me know if real power
wants a magazine or something I've
already done a separate video for that
fake Infinity Gauntlet moment so you can
check that out if you want to learn why
it was it existed in the first place and
what their original ideas about that
were but there was a whole bunch of
funny references to previous movies the
play at the beginning of the movie was a
version of the events of Thor the dark
world where Thor thought Loki sacrificed
himself that was Matt Damon and that was
Sam Neill so you can guess that there as
Guardians in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe now so maybe they got away with
the rest of the characters maybe they
were killed by hella and that first
assault the extra funny thing is that
the person playing Thor during the play
was Chris Hemsworth's brother Luke
Hemsworth
you probably remember him from Westworld
when Thor gets captured on Sekar and
they put him in that chair that takes
him down the line explaining what's
going to happen to him and what the
contest of Champions is they played the
music from the Willy Wonka movie when
everybody goes on that creepy ride and
it turns into that crazy nightmare acid
trip so not all of the Easter eggs were
for Marvel things it on top of all that
if you remember the shake weight the
scourge was playing with at the
beginning of the movie that was actually
brought from the set of the Green
Lantern movie that a director starred in
as an actor so he was calling that sort
of a backdoor DC Comics Easter Egg
Fenris wolf is also right out of the
comics scourge his guns might have
seemed weird in the movie because they
have way more powerful Asgardian weapons
but he used them in the comics so that's
probably why they included them in the
film and his name is scourge the
executioner in the comics so that's
probably why they added that subplot
about hella being Odin's former
executioner so that she could give him
that name you're my new executioner I
think almost everybody in my theater
understood the Black Widow music in the
line hey big guy Suns getting real low
he's wearing Tony Stark's clothes Point
Break was what Tony Stark called him
during the Avengers movie that's why
he's like damn it's dark and then when
the grand master asks Loki if he knows
whoo Thor is he says yes he's my brother
he's adopted
that was what Thor said during the
Avengers movie when the other Avengers
were complaining about him the
Grandmaster that they steel is
actually patterned to look like the
Maori flag so if you're from New Zealand
you probably recognized that that was a
bit of a deep cut but obviously you
remember a chord he debuted during the
journey into mystery comics he's been a
big comic book character for a while the
characters coorg
and meek were also part of Hulk's
warbound during the Planet Hulk
storyline when Helen Thor are going at
it in the throne room he says my father
told me once that a good King never
seeks out war but he's always prepared
for it that was a line of dialogue from
the first Thor film and then they used
the same music cue from the beginning of
the first Thor film when Thor's walking
into the throne room he's supposed to
become King Odin's getting ready to pass
it to him the same music Hugh plays when
Thor's walking to the front of the ship
at the end of the movie and sort of
officially assumes the mantle of king of
new Asgard the story that Thor tells
about Loki turning him into a frog isn't
exactly like it happens in the comics
there is a frog Thor but it's actually a
separate character who's an intelligent
frog that Thor finds he eventually
becomes a hero and wields a version of
Mjolnir himself - the story about Loki
turning himself into a snake is actually
about the Midgard serpent which is also
a slightly different character but it's
just sort of a funny way of telling that
story the club that he wields inside the
contest of Champions looks exactly like
Hercules club from the comics a lot of
people are taking this to mean that they
will do the character eventually but I
think there's just sort of a funny wink
at the idea of Thor and Hercules being
fairly similar characters although
technically Hercules is more of a
demigod but he is one of the Avengers in
the comics right now everybody in my
theater went crazy for the Stan Lee
cameo he was the guy that gave Thor the
haircut when he screams the wrath of
Mighty Thor Mighty Thor is just one of
the different runs of the Thor comics
probably one of the coolest Easter eggs
was when Thor disguised the hammer as
the umbrella that was a reference to the
Donald Blake era when he was banished to
earth he had to walk around in that
other human persona and didn't
who he was when he wanted to summon the
power authority would stomp the stick on
the ground and transform himself in the
hammer would transform as well most of
all the stuff on Sekar was taken from
Jack Kirby drawn designs all of the
Grand Master's soldiers were made to
look like the Celestials which are Jack
Kirby characters there's even a pattern
here taken from a Fantastic Four Jack
Kirby comic I think they were able to
sneak that in because they weren't
literally doing Fantastic Four stuff and
most people probably won't notice it but
let me know in the comments have you
spotted any other Easter eggs that I
didn't mention in the video what will
happen is is I'll do another video for
infinity war Thor relative power the new
weapon that he's going to wheel during
infinity war because his hammer is still
destroyed at the end of the movie so
there's a new round of that ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video on us a new winner when I
post that next Marvel video you can
click here for my infinity war promo for
all of the infinity gems as of the end
of Ragnarok and you can click here for
my post credits scene video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
you